good morning believe nation today's
message is be who you are over to you
Macklemore TV go don't let people's
outside perspectives change what you do
change who you are dictate your
happiness dictate your level of
self-worth affect your self-esteem and
as an artist that's easier said than
done the the public's perception does
weigh on you the box that they put you
in does affect you and I think that it's
a constant fight to remember why you
make music who you do it for why it's
important and to follow your process and
to not let anybody's outside opinion
dictate who you are you know it when
you're first starting any kind of
project is going to be a lot of unknowns
there's gonna be a lot of holes right if
you have a great idea for a business
that you come up with two in the morning
you know you don't have all the answers
yet right there's a lot of things that
you haven't figured out yet and a lot of
times what happens is you go and you
tell somebody about it and and they'll
poke holes in it right they'll tell you
oh it's not going to work because of
this and this and that's or you know you
don't have the education do that or you
don't have the money or resources to be
able to do that or you know what makes
you think that you're good enough to
start this company and a lot of times
you'll double yourself because there are
holes and they're just kind of poking at
you and it's really hard to say
confident in that you know what you what
you want to do is important and will
work out when the people around you're
just kind of hoping those holds and I
call those people the little man it's
appropriate that I'm wearing this shirt
today kill the little man say no to the
little man not allowed in your life you
know the friends that you have with
people who will find the holes in your
plane and support you and say hey you
know here's something that's wrong but
here's here's a way that I think you can
fix it these are people who may love you
right it could be friends family people
who love who they were
see you be successful but because what
you're doing is so far outside their
realm of comfort that their version of
showing you love is is discouraging you
from doing this plan because in their
mind what you're doing is too risky you
know you should be doing something safer
you should be going down that road and
so what they're saying is I love but
it's not helpful it's not constructive
it's not what you need to get to where
you want to go the most important thing
is if you feel like something has to get
done you feel in your heart that this
needs to be created that you go out and
do it the idea for little men came from
a guy who was in my life who I showed a
video to it was the believe by first
believed by video that I created and it
was six minutes long and this is a guy
in the in the in the business of video
so you understood the video business not
not some outsider who didn't understand
videos he's in the business of videos
and I shouldn't the video and he hated
it and he said no video should be six
minutes long and all these reasons why
this video would never work out and it's
easy to listen to the expert right it's
easy to listen to the guy who's supposed
to know what he's talking about and when
he said it's not going to work I think
in older an older version of avatar
younger Evan might have listened to him
but I watched the video and I'm like
this is amazing it made me feel
something and so you know what I don't
care if it doesn't work I still need to
do it if anything just not to live my
life would regret wondering what could
happen if i got it at now fortunately
the video did well i got over a million
views is one of the first big videos
that I had on my channel and that was a
valuable lesson for me and that even
sometimes people who are the experts
they don't know what they're talking
about either and ultimately I listened
to my heart I want to be Who I am I want
to create the things that I feel excited
about even if nobody else feels excited
about it and that doesn't mean that it
always works out because I've launched
projects that
failed and that haven't gone well it
doesn't mean that always works out but
it does mean one if you want to create
something great it's going to come from
something that you love you mean I know
which which one it is but it's going to
come from something that you love and
have a passion for the answer isn't to
be somebody else's version of you
because then you're going to create a
mediocre product or service so that part
of a goal that amazing future life for
yourself is only going to come from
creating something that you are
passionate about and to it again make
sure that you don't live with regret
that you don't think I think I had that
idea i just didn't do anything about it
and i wish i did and i don't want to
live that kind of life where I'm kicking
myself wondering what could have
happened if I did this action right so
instead of worrying about that just go
and do it and try and be you and trust
your process and sometimes it'll work
and sometimes it won't and that's okay
you'll learn each time you won't live
with regret and one of those projects
will lead to your ultimate happiness and
building something that has lasting
value that then you can go and tell your
grandkids I meet this look what I did
and build a legacy for yourself so the
question 30 today is I want to know who
around you is not supportive of your
idea right now who's holding you back
who's telling you can't do it and
hopefully by sharing you'll get some
support from believe nation to tell you
that you can do and give you some
confidence and keep going so who's who's
the little man in your life right now
leaving the comments below and I'll join
the discussion I'm also trying to get to
1 million subscribers in this channel so
anything you can do that you can think
of the help share it tweet it out of the
playlist tell people about it I'd really
really really super appreciate it thank
you guys sort you're watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot event specimen
for this recipe me go